you ever see some of these companies
valuation this company's worth 220
billion dollars this one worth six
billion dollars this one only after two
years worth 680 million dollars why and
how it's called the subscription economy
according to a Forbes article it says
two companies same top line revenue 100
million 100 million this one has to go
chase for its Revenue every single month
they got to go sell again but this one
it's subscription every month people are
paying 49.99 according to this Forbes
article this one could be worth eight
times more just because it's reoccurring
versus this one there's a reason for
that we're going to talk about that
today all right so if you get value out
of this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel but let's get
right into it on average you and I spent
237 dollars per month in subscription
model products that's three thousand
dollars per year give or take and
according to McKinsey and Company
subscription model products in the last
seven years have increased 350 percent
but the question becomes has this always
been around since the 20s maybe the 50s
or maybe 90s nope it started in the
2000s let me explain to you what's
happened to some of these numbers since
2000 according to report McKenzie
company that in 2000 only one percent of
companies offered a subscription service
so if you look at this 2000 was one
percent 2005 went to five percent two
thousand and ten ten percent two
thousand fifteen twenty percent two
thousand and twenty thirty five percent
it's estimated to be at fifty percent by
2025. now watch according to a report by
the conference board the average
consumer has 2.2 subscription in 2000
and look how it's gone up in 2005 3.4
2010 4.3 and 2015 5.5 then 6.7 in 2023
10.6 that means you and I have roughly
11 different things we subscribe for on
a monthly basis that helps increase the
valuation of these companies now you may
be watching the same but Pat when I
think about subscription I only think
about Netflix Spotify or Amazon so let's
take a look at this launch your Netflix
got started in 1997 Spotify in 2008
Amazon Prime in 2005. pricing when they
started doing their monthly subscription
Netflix is 8.99 a month it starts at
9.99 at Spotify and 12.99 and Amazon
Prime let's take a look at a number of
subscribers of 2021 Netflix that's over
200 million Spotify has over 365 million
obviously that includes both free and
paid and Amazon Prime is estimated to be
over 150 million so let's take a look at
Revenue in 1998 when Netflix got started
they did roughly 1.8 million in 99 to
14.4 million two thousand they did 49.3
2001 they did 103 million give or take
and by the way today their top line
revenue is 32 billion dollars Netflix 32
billion dollars worth roughly 200
billion dollars let's take a look at
Spotify Spotify in 2010 Revenue was 155
million it jumped with 330 million in
2011 last year roughly 12.35 5 billion
dollars in a year Spotify and last but
not least Amazon so now keep in mind
Amazon originally got started in 95 but
they did not get into subscription until
2005 when they launched Amazon Prime
look what happened to their numbers
before Prime in 2004 they were doing 6.9
billion in 2005 when they started Prime
they went to 14.1 billion and you know
what they did last year a little over
350 billion dollars so now if you're
like me like that but give me a break
we're talking about Netflix Amazon it's
not not every industry can really do a
subscription model really let's take a
look at other Industries here's some
Industries software we got Adobe
Creative Cloud and Microsoft 365 Beauty
we have Birchbox and Ipsy fashion we
have Stitch fix and Rent the Runway you
can literally rent the dress they're
wearing Hollywood three thousand dollar
dress for a hundred dollars a day or you
can ask them to send you clothes every
single month you give them the size your
flavor what you like 300 a month every
month something's being sent to your way
it's purely a subscription model meal
kids blue apron or hello fresh Fitness
Peloton or Beachbody on demand books
audible or Kindle wine you got wink and
vinebox cough you got Trade coffee and
Atlas coffee Home Goods you got Grove
collaborative and you have bespoke posts
pet supplies you got BarkBox and kidnap
box health and wellness you have
headspace and calm personal development
you have master class and blankets
language learning you have Rosetto Stone
and Duolingo plus crafts and do it
yourself you have craftsy and Crafters
box education you have udemy and
Coursera and by the way I've been in the
insurance space for a long time why do
you think these businesses are worth as
much as they do because insurance is
what reoccurring auto insurance
reoccurring health insurance reoccurring
so now what are the advantages of having
a subscription model as a company number
one you have recurring Revenue number
two scalability number three customer
retention number four enhanced customer
engagement five improved brand Image six
rapid growth seven diverse industry
presence a data driven insights nine
flexibility and scalability 10
Innovative pricing structure 11 Market
disruption 12 expansion into B2B space
and just like any other business if you
don't take care of your customers
they're going to go somewhere else which
means you're dealing with the downfall
of churn you got to keep showing up
competition you got to keep getting
better compliance you got to make sure
you meet those guidelines so now you may
be watching St Pat I'm not Netflix I'm
not Amazon I'm not Spotify what do I do
about this look the whole purpose of
this video is to get you thinking before
you say you know what what can I do with
this material maybe talk to your wife
talk to your business partner talk to
your peers and say how can we make this
thing more recurring FYI
you want to figure right away how to do
that at the David Consulting we have
multiple different masterminds where
these are the types of conversations we
have with other entrepreneurs on how
they're doing it so you can also pick up
some of their strategies if you want to
find out how to get on one of those
masterminds at the David Consulting
click on the link below in the
description and number two if you just
want to ask me a question or Tom
Ellsworth on how to get this going as
well on my neck if you've not downloaded
the app connect click here download the
app connect and you and I will get a
chance to have a minute to connect on
any questions you may have for us take
care everybody
foreign
[Music]